mr. Jung mr. scowl and to all of the
members of the Nobel Committee ladies
and gentlemen it is impossible to begin
this lecture without again expressing my
deep appreciation to the Nobel Committee
of the Norwegian Parliament for
bestowing upon me and the civil rights
movement in the United States such a
great honor occasionally in life that of
those moments of unutterable fulfillment
which cannot completely be explained by
those symbols called words their meaning
can only be articulated by the inaudible
language of the heart and such as the
moment I am presently experiencing I
experienced this high and joyous moment
not for myself alone but for those
devotees of non-violence who have moved
so courageously against around pots of
racial injustice and who in the process
have acquired a new estimate of their
own human worth many of them are young
and cultured others are middle-aged and
middle class the majority are poor and
untutored but they are all united in the
quiet conviction that it is better to
suffer in dick
then accept segregation in humiliation
they are the real heroes of the freedom
struggle
they are the noble people for who might
accept the Nobel Peace Prize I would
like to say also that it is a habit
experience and to know that so many
friends who have worked closely with me
over the last few years in this struggle
were willing to go into their
pocketbooks and their means and their
humble financial situations and to come
to Oslo to be a part of this experience
and naturally it is a great pleasure and
privilege to have my devoted wife my
mother and father my sister and brother
and among the many other friend my
closest sociate one who has been the
dearest friend to me in this struggle
Ralph David Abernathy
I would also like to say just a word
about the many courtesies extended by
the Norwegian people I have traveled in
many lands and many places over the
world but very seldom if ever have I
found people more friendly than the
people of Norway and we will long
remember all of the courtesies extended
and your great friendliness and I
particularly want to thank the committee
especially mr. John for the eloquent
words that he uttered yesterday at the
ceremony and yesterday evening at the
banquet and I can assure you that all of
these expressions of support of
inestimable value for the continuance of
my humble efforts and to make
brotherhood freedom and justice
realities in the United States of
America this evening I would like to use
this lofty and historic platform and to
discuss what appears to me to be the
most pressing problem confronting
mankind today modern man has brought the
whole world to an awe-inspiring
threshold of the future he has reached
new and astonishing peaks of scientific
success he has produced machines that
think and instruments appear into the
unfathomable ranges of interstellar
space he has built gigantic bridges to
span the seas
and gargantuan buildings to kiss the
skies here's our planes and spaceships
have dwarf distance placed time and
chains and carved the highways through
the stratosphere and this is a dazzling
picture of modern man's scientific and
technological progress yet in spite of
these spectacular strides and science
and technology and still unlimited ones
to come something basic is missing and
that is a sort of poverty of the spirit
which stands in glaring contrast to our
scientific and technological abundance
the richer we have become materially the
poorer we have become morally and
spiritually we have learned to fly the
air like the birds and swim the sea like
fish but we have not learned the simple
art of living together as brothers every
man lives in two realms the internal and
the external and the internal is that
realm of spiritual ends expressed in art
literature morals and religion the
external is that complex of devices
techniques mechanisms and
instrumentalities by means of which we
live our problem today is that we have
allowed the internal to become lost in
the external we have allowed the means
by which we live to our distance the
ends for which we live and so much of
modern life can be summarized in that
wresting dictum of the port the road
improved means to an unimproved end this
is a serious predicament the deep and
haunting problem confronting modern man
if we are to survive today our moral and
spiritual lag must be eliminated enlarge
material power spelled in large peril if
that is not proportionate growth of the
soul when the without of man's nature
subjugates the within dog storm clouds
began to form in the world and the
problem of spiritual and moral lag which
constitutes modern man's chief dilemma
it's presses itself in three larger
problems which grow out of man's ethical
infantile ISM each of these problems
while appearing to be separate and
isolated is inextricably bound to the
other I referred to racial injustice
poverty and war the first problem that I
would like to mention is racial
injustice the struggle to eliminate the
evil of racial injustice and constitutes
one of the major struggles of our time
in the present upsurge of the Negro
people of the United States grows out of
a deep and passionate determination to
make freedom and equality a reality here
and now in one sense the civil rights
movement in the United States is a
special American phenomenon which must
be understood in the light of American
history and dealt with in terms of the
American situation
but on another and more important level
what is happening in the United States
today is a relatively small part of a
world development we live in a day says
a philosopher Alfred North Whitehead
when civilization is shifting its basic
outlook a major turning point in history
where the presuppositions on which
society is structured are being analyzed
sharply challenged and profoundly
changed what we are seeing now is a
freedom explosion the realization of an
idea whose time has come to use Victor
Hugo's phrase the deep rumbling of
discontent that we hear today is a
thunder of disinherited masses rising
from dungeons of oppression to the
bright heels of freedom in one majestic
chorus the rising masses are singing in
the words of our freedom song and gone
let nobody turn us around all over the
world like a fever the freedom movement
is spreading in the widest liberation in
history the great masses of people are
determined to end the exploitation of
their races and their lands they are
awake and moving toward their goal like
a tidal wave you can hear them rumbling
in every village Street on the docks and
the houses among the students in the
churches and at political meetings
historic movement was for several
centuries and that of the nations and
societies of Western Europe out into the
rest of the world and conquests of
various sorts that period the era of
colonialism is at an end
East is meeting West the earth is being
redistributed
yes we are shifting our basic outlooks
now these developments should not
surprise in a student of history
oppressed people cannot remain remain
oppressed forever
the yearning for freedom eventually
manifests itself and the Bible tells the
thrilling story of how Moses stood in
Pharaoh's caught centuries ago and cried
let my people go
this is a kind of opening chapter in a
continuing story the present struggle in
the United States is a later chapter in
the same unfolding story something
within has reminded the Negro of his
birthright of freedom and something
without has reminded him that it can be
gained consciously unconsciously
he has been caught up by the zeitgeist
and with his black brothers of Africa
and his brown and yellow brothers in
Asia South America and the Caribbean the
United States Negro is moving with a
sense of great urgency toward the
promised land of racial justice
fortunately some significant strides
have been made in the struggle to end a
long night of racial injustice we have
seen the Magnificent drama of
Independence unfold in Asian in Africa
just 30 years ago there are only three
independent nations in the whole of
Africa but today 35 African nations have
risen from colonial bondage in the
United States we have witnessed the
gradual demise of the system of racial
segregation the Supreme Court's decision
of 1954 outlawing segregation in the
public school
gave a legal and constitutional
deathblow to the whole doctrine of
separate but equal the court decreed
that separate facilities are inherently
unequal and that the segregated child on
the basis of his race is to deny that
child equal protection of the law
this decision came as a great beacon
light of hope to millions of
disinherited people then came that
glowing day a few months ago when a
strong civil rights bill became the law
of the land this bill which was first
recommended and promoted by President
Kennedy was passed because of the
overwhelming support and perseverance
from millions of Americans Negro and
white it came as a bright interlude in
the long and sometimes turbulent
struggle for civil rights the beginning
of a second Emancipation Proclamation
providing a comprehensive legal basis
for equality of opportunity the sense of
passage of this bill we have seen some
encouraging and surprising signs of
compliance I'm happy to report that by
and large communities all over the
southern part of the United States are
obeying the civil rights law and showing
remarkable good sense in the process
another indication that progress is
being made was found in the recent
presidential election in the United
States the American people revealed
great maturity by overwhelmingly
rejecting a presidential candidate who
had become identified with extremism
racism and retrogression the voters of
our nation rendered a telling blow to
Radek right they defeated those elements
in our society which seek to pit quite
against Negro and lead the nation down a
dangerous fascist path now let me not
leave you with a false impression the
problem is far from solved we still have
a long long way to go before the dream
of freedom is a reality for the Negro in
the United States to put it figuratively
in biblical language we have left the
dust assaults of Egypt and crossed a red
sea whose waters had for years been
hardened by long and piercing wintered
of massive resistance but before we
reach cement majestic shores of the
promised land that is a frustrating and
bewildering wilderness ahead we must
still face prodigious hilltops of
opposition and gigantic mountains of
resistance but with patient and firm
determination we will press on until
every valley of despair is exalted to
new peaks of hope until every mounting
of pride and irrationality is made low
by the leavening process of humility and
compassion until the rough places of
injustice are transformed into a small
plain of equality and opportunity and
until the crooked places of prejudice
the transformed by the straightening
process a bright-eyed wisdom what the
main sections of the civil rights
movement in the United States are saying
is that the demand for dignity equality
jobs and citizenship will not be
abandoned or deluded or postponed if
that means resistance and conflict we
shall not flinch we shall not be cowed
we are no longer afraid the word that
symbolizes the spirit and the outward
farmer of our encounter is non-violence
and it is doubtless that factor which
made it seem appropriate to award a
peace prize to one identified with
struggle broadly speaking non-violence
in the civil rights struggle has meant
not relying on arms and weapons for
struggle it has meant non cooperation
with customs and laws which are
institutional aspects of a regime of
discrimination and enslave enslavement
it has meant direct participation of
masses in protest
rather than reliance on indirect methods
which frequently do not involve masses
in action at all non-violence has also
meant that my people in the agonizing
struggles of recent years have taken
suffering upon themselves instead of
inflicting it on others it has meant as
I said that we are no longer afraid and
card but in some substantial degree it
has meant that we do not want to instill
fear in others or into the society of
which we are a part the movement does
not seek to liberate Negroes at the
expense of the humiliation and
enslavement of whites it seeks no
victory over anyone it seeks to liberate
American society and to share in the
self liberation of all the people
violence as a way of achieving racial
justice is I am convinced both
impractical and immoral I'm not a
mindful of the fact that violence often
brings about momentary results
nations have frequently won their
independence in battle but in spite of
temporary victories violence never
brings permanent peace it solves no
social problems it merely creates new
and more complicated ones violence is
impractical impractical because it is a
descending spiral ending in destruction
for all it is immoral because it seeks
to humiliate the opponent rather than
when his understanding it seeks to
annihilate rather than convert violence
is immoral because it thrives on hatred
rather than love it destroys community
and makes Brotherhood impossible
it leaves society and monologue rather
than dialogue violence ends up defeating
itself
it creates bitterness in the survivors
and brutality and the destroyers in a
real sense non-violence seeks to redeem
the spiritual and moral leg that I spoke
of earlier as the chief dilemma of
modern man it seeks to secure moral ends
through moral means non-violence is a
powerful and just weapon indeed it as a
weapon unique in history which cuts
without wounding and ennobles a man who
wills it I believe in this method
because I think it is the only way to
reestablish the broken community it is a
method which seeks to implement the just
law by appealing to the conscience of
the great decent majority who through
blindness fear pride and irrationality
have allowed their conscience is to
sleep the nonviolent resistors can
summarize a message
in the following simple terms we will
take direct action against injustice
despite the failure of governmental and
other official agencies to act first we
will not obey unjust laws our submit to
unjust practices we will do this
peacefully
openly cheerfully because our aim is to
persuade we adopt the means of
non-violence because our end is a
community at peace with itself we will
try to persuade with our words but if
our words fail we will try to persuade
with our acts we will always be willing
to talk and seek fair compromise but we
are ready to suffer when necessary and
even risk our lives in order to become
witnesses to truth as we see it this
approach to the problem is not at all
without successful precedent it was used
in a magnificent way by Mohandas K
Gandhi to challenge the might of the
British Empire and free his people from
the political domination an economic
exploitation inflicted upon them for
centuries he struggle only with the
weapons of truth soul force non-injury
and courage in the past ten years
unarmed gallant men and women of the
United States have given living
testimony to the moral power and
efficacy of non-violence by the
thousands and faceless anonymous
relentless young people black and white
if temporary temporarily left the ivory
tower walls of
learning to stomp the barricades of bias
they're courageous and discipline
activities have come as a refreshing
oasis in a desert sweltering with the
heat of injustice they have taken our
whole nation back to those great wells
of democracy which were dug deep by the
founding fathers in the formulation of
the Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence one day all of America will
be proud of that achievements I'm only
too well aware of the human weaknesses
and failures which exist the doubts
about the efficacy of non-violence and
the open advocacy of violence by some
but I am still convinced that
non-violence is both the most
practically sound and morally excellent
way to grapple with the age-old problem
of racial injustice a second evil which
plagues the modern world is that of
poverty like a monstrous octopus it
protects its nagging prehensile
tentacles in lands and villages all over
the world almost two-thirds of the
peoples of the world go to bed hungry at
night
they are undernourished ill housed and
shabbily clad many of them have no
houses of beds to sleep in the only beds
are the sidewalks of the cities and the
dusty roads of the villages most of
these poverty-stricken children of God
have never seen a physician or a dentist
this problem of poverty is not only seen
in the class division between the highly
in developed industrial nations and the
so called
underdeveloped nations
it is seen in the great economic gaps
within the rich nations themselves take
my own country for example we have
developed the greatest system of
production that history has ever known
we have become the richest nation in the
world our national gross product this
year will reach the astounding figure of
almost six hundred and fifty billion
dollars yet at least one-fifth of our
fellow citizens some ten million
families comprising about 40 million
individuals are bound to a miserable
culture of poverty in a sense of poverty
of the poor in America is more
frustrating than the poverty of Africa
in Asia the misery of the poor in Africa
in Asia is shared misery a fact of life
for the vast majority they are all poor
together as a result of years of
exploitation and under development in
sad contrast the poor in America know
that they live in the richest nation in
the world and that even though they are
perishing on a lonely island of poverty
they are surrounded by a vast ocean of
material prosperity glistening towers of
glass and steel easily seen from their
slum dwellers spring up almost overnight
jetliner speed over their get holes at
six hundred miles an hour
satellites streaked through outer space
and reveal details of the moon President
Johnson in his State of the Union
message emphasizing entr diction and he
heralded the United States highest
standard of living in the world and
deplored that it was accompanied by
dislocation loss of jobs and the specter
of poverty in the midst of Plenty
so it is obvious that if man is to
redeem his spiritual and moral AG he
must go all out to brids of social and
economic gulf between the haves and the
have-nots of the world poverty is one of
the most urgent items on the agenda of
modern life that is nothing new about
poverty
what is new however is that we have the
resources to get rid of it more than a
century and a half ago people began to
be disturbed about the twin problems of
population and production a thoughtful
Englishman named Malthus wrote a book
that set forth some rather frightening
conclusions he predicted that the human
family was gradually moving toward
global starvation because the world was
producing people faster than it was
producing food and material to support
them later scientists however disproved
the conclusions of Malthus and revealed
that he had vastly underestimated the
resources of the world and the
resourcefulness of man not too many
years ago dr. Kurt Li Mathur a Harvard
geologist wrote a book entitled enough
into spell he said for the basic theme
that famine is wholly unnecessary in the
modern world today therefore the
question on the agenda must read Why
should there be hunger and privation in
any land in any city at any table when
man has the resources and the scientific
know-how to provide all mankind with the
basic necessities of life even deserts
can be irrigated
and topsoil can be replaced we cannot
complain of a lack of land for that of
25 million square miles of tillable land
of which we are using less than seven
million we have amazing knowledge of
vitamins nutrition the chemistry of food
and the versatility of atoms that is no
deficit in human resources the deficit
is in human will the well-off and the
secure have to often become indifferent
and oblivious to the poverty and
deprivation in their midst the poor in
our countries have been shut out of our
minds and driven from the mainstream of
our societies because we have allowed
them to become invisible
just as non-violence expose the ugliness
of racial injustice so must the
infection and sickness of poverty be
exposed and heal not only its symptoms
but its basic causes this too will be a
fierce struggle and we must not be
afraid to pursue the remedy no matter
how formidable the task the time has
come for an all-out war against poverty
the rich nations must use their vast
resources of wealth to develop the
undeveloped school the unschool and feed
the unfair ultimately a great nation is
a compassionate nation no individual a
nation can be great if it does not have
a concern for the least of these deeply
etched in the fiber of our religious
tradition is a conviction that men are
made in the image of God and that they
are souls of infinite metaphysical value
the heirs of a legacy of dignity and
worth if we feel this as a profound
moral fact we cannot be content to see
men hung
to see men victimized with starvation
and ill health when we have the means to
help them the wealth of nations must go
all out to bridge the gulf between the
rich minority and the poor majority in
the final analysis the rich must not
ignore the poor because both rich and
poor are tied together in a single
garment of destiny all life is
interrelated and all men are
interdependent the agony of the poor
diminishes our rich and the salvation of
the poor enlarges our rich we are
inevitably our brother's keeper because
of the interrelated structured of
reality John Donne interpreted this
truth in graphic terms when he affirmed
no man is an island entire of itself
every man is a piece of the continent a
part of the main if a cloud be washed
away by the sea Europe is the less as
well as if a promontory world as well as
if a man order thy friends of thine
ownself were any man's death diminishes
me because I am involved in mankind and
therefore never send to know For Whom
the Bell Tolls it tolls for thee
a third great evil confronted our world
is that of war recent events have this
vividly reminded us that nations are not
reducing but rather increasing their
Arsenal's of weapons of mass destruction
the best brains and the highly developed
nations of the world are devoted to
military technology the proliferation of
nuclear weapons has not been halted in
spite of the limited test ban treaty on
the contrary
the dito nation of an atomic device by
the first non-white non-western and
so-called underdeveloped power namely
the Chinese People's Republic opens new
vistas of exposure of vast multitudes
ahold of humanity to insidious
terrorization by the ever-present threat
of annihilation the fact that most of
the time human beings put the truth
about the nature and risk of the nuclear
war out of their minds because it is too
painful and therefore not acceptable
does not alter the nature and risk of
such a war the device of rejection may
temporarily covered up anxiety but it
does not bestow a peace of mind and
emotional security so man's proneness to
engage in war is still a fact but wisdom
born of experience should tell us that
Ward is obsolete there may have been a
time when war served as a negative good
by preventing the spread and growth of
an evil force but the destructive power
of modern weapons eliminates even the
possibility that war may serve as a
negative good if we assume that life is
worth living and that man has a right to
survive then we must find an alternative
to war in a day when vehicles hurtle
through outer space and guided ballistic
missiles carve highways of death through
the stratosphere no nation can claim
victory in war the so called limited war
will leave little more than a calamitous
legacy of human suffering political
turmoil and political disillusionment a
world war god forbid will leave only
smoldering ashes as a mute test
a human race whose father led inexorably
to ultimate death and so of modern man's
can man continues to flirt
unhesitatingly with war he will
transform his earthly habitat into an
infernal such as even the mind of Dante
could not imagine therefore i adventure
to suggest to all of you and all who
hear and may eventually read these words
that the philosophy and strategy of
non-violence become immediately a
subject for study and for serious
experimentation in every field of human
conflict by no means excluding the
relations between nations
it is after all nation-states which made
war which have produced the weapons
which threaten the survival of mankind
and which are both genocidal and
suicidal in character here also we have
ancient habits to deal with vast
structures of power indescribable
complicated problems to solve but unless
we abdicate our humanity altogether and
succumb to fear and importance in the
presence of the weapons we have
ourselves created it is imperative and
urgent to put an end to war and violence
between nations as it is to put an end
to racial injustice equality with whites
will hardly solve the problems of either
White's or Negroes if it means equality
and a society under the spell of terror
and a world
doomed to extinction I do not wish to
minimum minimize the complexities of the
problems that need to be faced in
achieving disarmament in peace but I
think it is a fact that we shall not
have the will the courage and the
insight to deal with such matters unless
in this field we are prepared to undergo
a mental and spiritual re-evaluation a
change of focus which will enable us to
see that the things which seemed most
real and powerful are indeed now unreal
and have come under the sentence of
death we need to make a supreme effort
to generate the readiness indeed the
eagerness to enter into the new world
which is now possible the city which
hath foundations whose builder and maker
is God we will not build a peaceful
world by following a negative path it is
not enough to say we must not wage war
it is necessary to love peace and
sacrifice for it we must concentrate not
merely on the negative explosion of war
but on the positive affirmation of peace
and that is a fascinating little story
that is preserved for us in Greek
literature about Ulysses and the sirens
the sirens had the ability to sing so
sweetly that sailors could not resist
steering toward their Island many ships
were lured upon the rocks and men forgot
home duty and honor as they flung
themselves into the sea to become
embrace bombs that drew them down to
death
Ulysses determined not to be lured by
the sirens first decided to tie himself
tightly to the mast of his boat and it's
in his crew stuff that years with wax
but finally he and his crew learned a
better way to save themselves they took
on board the beautiful singer obvious
whose melodies were sweeter than the
music of the sirens
when Orpheus sang who bothered to listen
to the sirens so we must fix our visions
not merely on the negative expulsion of
war but upon the positive affirmation of
peace we must see that piece represents
a sweeter music a cosmic melody that is
far superior to the discards of war
somehow we must transform the dynamics
of the world power struggle from the
negative nuclear arms race which no one
can win through a positive contest to
harness man's creative genius for the
purpose of making peace and prosperity a
reality for all of the nations of the
world in short we must shift the arms
race into a peace race if we have the
will and determination to mount such a
peace offensive we will unlock hither do
hitherto
sealed doors of hope and transform our
eminent cosmic elegy into a psalm of
creative fulfillment all that I have
said boils down to the point of
affirming that mankind's survival is
dependent upon man's ability to solve
the problems of racial injustice poverty
and war the solution of these problems
is in turn dependent upon men squaring
his moral progress with his scientific
progress and learning the practical art
of living in harmony some years ago two
novelist died among his papers was found
a list of suggested story plots for
further stories the most prominently
underscored being this one a widely
separated family inherits a house in
which they have to live together this is
a great new problem of mankind we have
inherited a big house a great world
house in which we have to live together
black men and white men Easterners and
Westerners Gentiles and Jews Catholics
and Protestants Muslims and Hindus a
family unduly separated in ideas culture
and interests who because we can never
again live without each other must learn
somehow in this one big world house to
live with each other and this is our
great
this means that more and more our
loyalty's must become ecumenical rather
than sectional we must now give an
overriding loyalty to mankind as a whole
in order to preserve the best in our
individual societies this call for a
worldwide fellowship that lifts let
neighborly concern beyond one's tribe
race class and nation is in reality a
call for all embracing and unconditional
love for all men this off misunderstood
and misinterpreted concept so readily
dismissed by the niches of the world as
a weak and cowardly force has now become
an absolute necessity for the survival
of man when I speak of love I'm not
speaking of some sentimental and weak
response which is little more than
emotional Bosh I'm speaking of that
force which all of the great religions
have seen as a supreme unifying
principle of life love is somehow the
key that unlocks the door which leads to
ultimate reality this Hindu Muslim
Christian Jewish Buddhist belief about
ultimate reality is beautifully summed
up in the First Epistle of st. John let
us love one another for love is of God
and every one that loveth is born of God
and knoweth God he that loveth not
knoweth not God for god is love if we
love one another god dwelleth in US and
his love is perfected in us let us hope
that this spirit will become the order
of the day
as arnold toynbee says love is the
ultimate force that makes for the saving
choice of life and good against a
damning choice of death and evil
therefore the first hope in our
inventory must be the hope that love is
going to have the last word we can no
longer afford to worship the god of hate
bow before the altars of retaliation the
oceans of history are made turbulent by
the ever rising tides of hate and
history is cluttered with the wreckage
of nations and individuals that pursued
this self-defeating path of hate love is
a key to the solution of the problem of
the world let me close by saying that I
have the personal faith and mankind will
somehow rise up to the occasion and give
new directions to an age drifting
rapidly and toward its doom in spite of
the tensions and uncertainties of this
period something profoundly meaningful
is taking place old systems of
exploitation and oppression of passing
away and out of the wombs of the frail
of a frail world new systems of justice
and equality of being born doors of
opportunity are gradually being open to
those at the bottom of society the
shirtless and barefoot people of the
land are developing a new sense of
somebody nests and carving a tunnel of
Hope through the dark mounting of
despair the people who sat in darkness
have seen a great light here and that an
individual or group dance to love and
rise us to the majestic heights of moral
maturity and so in a real sense this is
a great time to be alive therefore I am
not yet discouraged about the future
granted that the easygoing optimism of
yesterday is impossible granted that
those who pioneer in the struggle for
peace and freedom will still face
uncomfortable jail sales painful threats
of death they will still be battered by
the storms of persecution leading them
to the nagging feeling at times that
they can no longer bear such a heavy
burden the temptation of wanting to
retreat to a more quiet and serene life
granted that we face a world crisis
which leaves us standing so often amid
the surging moment of life's Restless
sea but every crisis has both its
dangers and its opportunities it can
spell either salvation or doom in a dark
confused world the kingdom of God may
yet reign in the hearts of men and we
will come to that great and glad day
when men all over the world will be able
to join hands black men and white men
Jews and Gentiles Protestants and
Catholics Hindus and Muslims and sing in
the words of the old Negro spiritual
free at last free at last thank God
Almighty we are free at last
you